in 2007 Lucy mirando a self-proclaimed
environmentalist takes over as the CEO
of the mirando corporation succeeding
her twin sister she reveals an ambitious
project the breeding of a special kind
of animal known as the Super Pig a total
of 26 Super Pig specimens are
distributed to Farmers worldwide and
after a decade one lucky Pig will be
crowned the ultimate winner fast forward
to the year 2017 where in South Korea
resides a young girl named Miha her
humble abode is shared with her caring
grandfather and a remarkable creature
known as oksha the Super Pig Miha and
okja share an Inseparable Bond spending
most of their time together their
friendship is so deep that at one point
oksha heroically saves Mia from a
treacherous fall off a cliff the
Tranquility of their existence is
shattered when a spokesperson for
mirando Corporation and a zoologist
named Dr Johnny Wilcox arrive with great
Fanfare Dr Wilcox proclaims okja as the
finest Super Pig and announces their
intention to transport her to the
bustling city of New York Mia's heart
breaks as her grandfather presents her
with a golden pig a symbol of his effort
to save up for a replacement in case
okja was taken away overwhelmed with
grief Miha embarks on a journey to Seoul
determined to find and rescue her
beloved friend in the sprawling City
Mia's desperate search leads her to a
heart-wrenching site okcha being loaded
onto a truck consumed by determination
Mia musters every ounce of strength and
chases down the vehicle however fate
intervenes as the truck is suddenly
intercepted by an organization known as
the animal Liberation Front or the ALF
the ALF an activist group fighting for
animal rights successfully rescues oksha
from the clutches of the mirando
corporation they oppose the unethical
treatment of animals and have vowed to
protect them from harm Mia initially
bewildered by their sudden intervention
soon realizes that she has found allies
in her quest to save oksha together with
the members of the ALF Miha embarks on a
perilous journey to liberate oksha from
the clutches of corporate greed they
face numerous challenges evading mirando
corporation's Relentless Pursuit and
encountering both exhilarating triumphs
and heart-wrenching setbacks along the
way in the face of intense challenges
Mia's unwavering during determination
and boundless affection for oksha shines
brightly offering a glimmer of hope
throughout their difficult Journey
supported by the unwavering resolve of
the animal Liberation Front Alf and
fueled by the unbreakable Bond they
share with the extraordinary Super Pig
Mia embarks on a daring quest to
overcome all obstacles and reclaim their
precious friendship in doing so she
fearlessly confronts the exploitative
practices of the mirando corporation
defying their oppressive ways and
striving for a future where compassion
and Justice Prevail in the resulting
chaos Mia and oksha managed to escape
but their freedom is short-lived soon
the animal Liberation Front led by a
determined individual named Jay comes to
their rescue Jay assigns another Alf
member K to translate their intentions
to Mia their plan involves implanting a
recording device in oksha's ear and
allowing her to be recaptured by the
mirando corporation capturing the
corporation's mistreatment of animals on
film trusting the ALF Mia agrees to
their proposal pleading with them to
return okya to the peaceful mountains
they call home in a heart-wrenching turn
of events K cunningly distorts me as War
words offering a deceptive translation
that convinces the unsuspecting girl
that everyone is on the same page a wave
of Sorrow engulfs Mia as she helplessly
Witnesses the departure of the animal
Liberation Front Alf who are now
whisking oksha away once again the poor
creature finds herself captured and
forcibly returned to the Relentless grip
of the mirando corporation in an attempt
to lessen the potential public relations
disaster Lucy the CEO of mirando
Corporation extends an offer to Miha she
agrees to sponsor Mia's journey to New
York City assuring her of a reunion with
her beloved Pig meanwhile oksha finds
herself confined to a laboratory where
she is subjected to forced breeding with
another Super Pig the corporation
further resorts to extracting flesh from
okcha's body for a taste test displaying
their heartless disregard for her
well-being upon witnessing the
distressing footage captured by the ALF
K finally confesses his deceit to the
rest of the group exposing his
manipulation of Mia's consent this
Revelation stirs intense anger within
Jay resulting in a physical altercation
between the two in response to Kay's
betrayal Jay expels him from the animal
Liberation Front severing ties with the
deceitful member the turn of events
leaves Miha and okja in dire
circumstances Mia now in New York City
must confront the reality of the
situation determined to save her friend
she embarks on a mission to expose the
mirando corporation's cruel practices
and rescue oksha from their clutches
once and for all United by their shared
desire for justice Mia and the remaining
members of the ALF joined forces in a
final attempt to liberate oksha and
bring an end to the corporation's
exploitation of these gentle creatures
in the bustling Streets of New York City
Miha finds herself caught up in the
demands of the mirando corporation
however amidst the chaos Jay manages to
sneak into Mia's room revealing a daring
plan to rescue okcha during a pivotal
stage performance the time has come for
Mia to confront the corporation head on
and fight for her treasured friend's
Freedom as the mirando parade unfolds a
battered and temporarily blinded oksha
unexpectedly lunges at Miha witnessing
the commotion Jay rushes to Mia's Aid
determined to protect her from oksha's
unintended aggression however Mia
refuses to let Jay harm okja displaying
a remarkable Bond of understand ending
with her beloved companion with gentle
words and a soothing touch she manages
to calm okja's tumultuous emotions in a
shocking turn of events the animal
Liberation Front seizes this opportune
moment to expose okja's mistreatment to
the unsuspecting public the footage
vividly captures the horrific reality of
the mirando corporation's practices
prompting a swift shift in public
sentiment the crowd swiftly turns
against the corporation condemning its
callous actions unable to withstand the
mounting pressure Lucy relinquishes
control of the company to her twin
sister Nancy however instead of seeking
reconciliation Nancy resorts to
employing a private security firm to
eliminate the remaining Alf members
oksha is once again seized by the
corporation and the ALF members find
themselves arrested and facing an
uncertain fate amidst the turmoil Mia
and Jay managed to elude capture thanks
to Kay's timely intervention together K
Mia and Jay embark on a mission to
locate okja leading them to a sprawling
processing plant there they witnessed
the heartbreaking side of okscha being
forcibly guided up a ramp toward
impending doom in the slaughterhouse
Miha fueled by her unwavering
determination presents a mirando
employee with a poignant photograph
capturing her and baby okja in happier
times touched by the heartfelt
connection portrayed in the picture the
employee hesitates momentarily halting
the cruel procession Nancy the new head
of mirando Corporation arrives on the
scene faced with an unexpected
proposition from Mia in a desperate plea
for oksha's Life Mia offers Nancy the
golden pig her grandfather bestowed upon
her swallowing her Pride Nancy accepts
the offer sealing the deal that would
spare oksha from imminent Slaughter in a
cruel twist J and K fall victim to
Nancy's machinations Mia and oksha are
LED away their future is uncertain
however as they make their departure a
pair of super pigs discreetly push their
newborn Offspring towards okja
entrusting her with their precious
secret the courageous journey of Miha
okja and their Newfound allies continues
as they navigate a world where corporate
greed and animal exploitation Collide
leaving an indelible mark on their path
to Liberation returning to the peaceful
Countryside Mia happily continues her
life alongside her beloved grandfather
and the adorable new piglet the rolling
Hills and picturesque Landscapes provide
the backdrop for their simple yet
fulfilling existence there's more to the
story though after the main events
unfold a post-credits scene takes us by
surprise Jay who was previously
imprisoned finally regains Freedom a
sense of Liberation fills the air as he
steps onto a bus joined by his loyal
companion K and the rest of their
organization intriguingly they have a
new member on board Kim wushick an
ex-driver who used to work for the
mighty morando Corporation as the bus
heads towards its destination their
Collective determination is palpable the
group is fueled by a fervent desire to
disrupt a highly significant mirando
shareholders meeting with Kim wushick's
Insider knowledge and the Relentless
Spirit of the organization they aim to
make a significant impact on mirando's
proceedings the once powerful
Corporation is about to face an
unexpected storm click on one of the
videos on your screen right now